نعم جلال في الحقيقه مهما استطعنا مهما
حاولنا ان نرصد الصوره المشهد الذي
ينقل لكم هذه الفرحه التي يعيشها
الارجنتينيون في كل مكان هنا داخل ووسط
العاصمه بونس ايرس وفي كل ارجاء الارجنتين
فاننا لن نتمكن من ذلك لا عدسات تستطيع ان
تظهر الصوره الحقيقيه ولا اي من الوسائل
تستطيع ان تظهر حجم الفرح حجم السعاده
بالنسبه للارجنتين بهذا الفوز على التاريخ
بالنسبه لهذه الفرحه التي انتظروها لسته
36 عاما بشكل متواصل همم هنا كانوا
يحاولون في كل مونديال ان يحصلوا على كاس
بقياده منتخبهم مع فريقهم ولكنهم لم
يستطيعوا الا انهم تمكنوا هذه المره في
اخر مونديال
يشارك وحققوا هذا الحلم وحصلوا على كاس
العالم في قطر
2022 جلال بالفعل هم نسوا كل شيء نسوا همم
الهموم الاقتصاديه المشاكل نسوا ان هناك
انتخابات قادمه في العام المقبل والمعركه
السياسيه محتدمه الناس وكل شيء الخلافات
جونيورز الناس وكل شيء وهمم ركزوا فقط على
هذا الفوز جماعههم حب الارجنتين جمعهم هذا
القميص المقلم باللون الازرق وحب
هذا الحلم بالحصول على كاس العالم للمره
الثالثه باضافه نجمه الى النجمتين التي
يضعوها على قميصهم كبار وصغار كما شاهدتم
نحن الان هنا همم على بعد امطار فقط من
الساحه الرئيسيه
يقفزون هنا هنا
يرفعون ايضا مجسماتك لكاس العالم بكل
الاشكال مجسمات بسيطه مجسمات متقنه
ويريدون ان يعبروا ان هذا الكاس سياتي
اليهم غدا ينتظرون ويترقبون ان يعود
المنتخب الوطني الارجنتيني يوم غد بقياده
الظاهره ميسي وهو يرفع هذا الكاس هنا في
مطار ايزيزا في العاصمه الارجنتينيوس
كان ينتظر هذه اللحظه تابعه المباراه لحظه
بلحظه كان يفرح مع كل هدف ثم يبكي بكاء
مريرا مع كل خساره او مع كل تسجيل هدف
لفرنسا ثم وصل الى ركلات الترجيح وراء
كانت الجزاء وتابع لحظه بلحظه كيف تتمكن
الارجنتينيون من تسجيلي لجميع الاهداف هو
يوم تاريخيا بالنسبه للارجنتين بكل
المقاييس بكل المقاييل ليس يوما همم
رياضيا فقط يوم اللي كره القدم
من معنى خلف هذا الفوز وخلفه هذه
الفرحت كانوا يغنون خلال الايام الماضيه
طيله الشهر الماضي خلال
بطوله كاس العالم اغنيه شهيره تقول اننا
سنحثر على النجمه الثالثه سنحصل على كاس
الثالث ويوم اليوم يحضرون لاغاني جديده
يقولون فيها اننا سنحصل على الكاس الرابع
الان يطمحونه بمونديال 2026 ويريدون ان
تستكمل هذه المسيره معنى تبقى من الفريق
بدون النجم الكبير ميسي
ظاهره التاريخيه التي يصفونها بانه افضل
لاعب كره قدم في التاريخ ماتوا اليوم
يفضلون ميسي على مارادونا هذا امر كبير
بالنسبه امرا مقدسا واليوم همم باتوا ايضا
ينظرون الى ليو ميسي على انه هذه
الظاهره